[Música]
el pasado 21 de marzo el presidente de
eeuu joe biden aseguró que su homólogo
ruso vladimir putin estaría considerando
recurrir a armas químicas y biológicas
en la invasión de ucrania sin embargo
las declaraciones del demócrata no
incluyeron pruebas repitiendo el mismo
esquema que usó días antes de rusia que
denunció ante naciones unidas a eeuu por
supuestamente financiar al gobierno de
volodymyr selenski en el desarrollo de
este armamento prohibido en un
laboratorio ucraniano sobre este tema
vamos al análisis con maría pía devoto
ella es coordinadora de la red de celac
de seguridad humana para américa latina
y el caribe especializada en derecho
internacional humanitario mariapia
gracias por estar con nosotros y cuál es
la diferencia entre un arma incendiaria
y una arma química porque sería grave
por ejemplo la confirmación del uso de o
de bombas de fósforo blanco en ucrania
bueno en principio tenían la experta
hablando de las diferencias que hay
entre las armas químicas y las
biológicas y hasta ahora hasta el
momento se han utilizado armas
convencionales
nosotros sabemos las armas
convencionales cuando vemos los tanques
rusos cuando se ven por ejemplo a estas
armas que están
capacitando a los civiles para
enfrentarse a la invasión y por el otro
lado tenemos lo que ya no es el
armamento convencional sino que son
armas de destrucción masiva y esto está
dicho por el alcance y estas armas de
destrucción masiva son las armas
nucleares las armas biológicas y las
armas químicas con las armas nucleares
ya sabemos esto es muy diferente y está
relacionado al alcance y a cómo se
pueden propagar por eso eso sería como
la diferencia principal pero son todas
armas prohibidas como decía la experta a
las armas nucleares están a pocos días
de la invasión
rusia puso sus armas nucleares en
régimen especial de combate en alerta
esto quiere decir que las armas pueden
ser utilizadas inmediatamente no quiere
decir que vayan a ser utilizadas sino
que tienen la posibilidad de y por el
otro lado están las armas biológicas y
las armas químicas que veíamos cuál es
el alcance que tienen y las diferencias
unas vienen de la naturaleza otras son
sustancias tóxicas convertidas en armas
como como el gas y si nosotros
recordamos ahí hay un ejemplo clarísimo
más allá que los que daban recordamos al
opositor ruso a naval ni que está preso
actualmente y si recuerdan que fue
envenenado en el 2020 con un con un
agente nervioso
novick entonces maría envía es que nos
hiciera que nos adelantáramos demasiado
en el tema porque quisiera ir a los
ejemplos de la utilización o de la
supuesta utilización de estas de estos
armamentos pero usted hace un segundo
decía que tanto las armas incendiarias
como las armas químicas están prohibidas
sin embargo esto motivo de debate más de
una vez en la historia teniendo en
cuenta además que eeuu ha utilizado
armas incendiarias en múltiples
ocasiones lo hizo en la segunda guerra
mundial contra los alemanes lo hizo en
faluyá irak en 2004 pese a que había
civiles y ahí fue cuando el gobierno
dijo que su uso era legítimo si estaba
dentro del contexto de la guerra
lo que tenemos en el derecho
internacional humanitario no es legítimo
el uso e incluso hay diferencias de las
de fósforos y de las armas incendiarias
entonces es es ex las ha utilizado
recientemente israel en el conflicto con
palestina ahora no es legítimo no se va
a permitir que sean utilizadas estas
armas en en ucrania el análisis es
porque está diciendo porque está
diciendo putin que hay desarrollo de
armas biológicas y químicas en ucrania
por qué por qué está diciendo eso que lo
mismo dijo que podría tener armas
nucleares lo está claramente lo está
diciendo porque está buscando argumentos
para justificar alguna acción de ahí es
que se toma el análisis de lo que dijo
vaivén de lo que dijeron en la cumbre
reciente cumbre de la otan en bruselas
de ese tema se toman el análisis es
decir si las han utilizado en el pasado
están diciendo que nosotros están justo
van a querer justificar su uso aparte
que se utilizaron en el 2017 fue porque
las utilizo al assad en síria que es el
aliado ruso claro eso fue haciendo un
poco de contexto pero ya viniendo al
presente usted cree que la confirmación
es del uso de armas químicas podría
precipitar una intervención directa de
occidente y además la otan dijo que iba
a fortalecer sus sistemas de defensa
química biológica y nuclear cómo sería
ese fortalecimiento para el cierre
en realidad es el análisis y el análisis
que hace occidente es que no se van a
utilizar ese tipo de armamento porque es
lo que se llama la teoría de la
destrucción mutua asegurada es como que
tengamos dos personas en una sala y en
esa sala tengan cinturones de nafta con
combustible y los dos tienen fósforos
pero no los utilizan no los utilizan
porque lo que va a suceder es que ambas
van esas dos personas van a arder
entonces una escalada en la utilización
de armas de destrucción masiva traería
la destrucción mutua asegurada el mundo
ya no sería nos en minutos misiles
intercontinentales destruyendo ciudades
enteras el mundo ya no sería tal como lo
conocemos millones de personas morirían
pero no solamente por el la utilización
de las armas en sí sino por la
contaminación del ambiente por la
escasez de alimento y por la hambruna
bueno pues que hiciera también
preguntarle acerca de la utilización de
las bombas de fósforo que denunció de
fósforo blanco que denunció el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr es el
esquí que tanto daño pueden producir y
habría una diferenciación si no se
hubieran utilizado como dijo selenski
contra la población civil
por supuesto que hay una diferenciación
y aparte ese tipo de armas son
como se llama la de fotos son
incendiarias las personas lo hemos visto
en conflictos recientes en palestina por
utilización de israel como les decía
anteriormente y no estaría probado la
utilización de este tipo de armamento
sin embargo después de que se hizo la
denuncia por parte de ucrania por
ejemplo el alcalde de ir pines cerca de
quien se publicó fotos en redes sociales
en las que se veía el cielo nocturno y
cayendo chispas desde el cielo unas
chispas blancas y ellos dicen que esa es
la prueba de que si se utilizó este
fósforo blanco contra la población
ucraniano usted cree que eso es
suficiente sabemos de todas maneras que
no está aprobado la información hasta
ahora es que no pero pero que nos dicen
esas imágenes
las imágenes nos dicen que la
utilización si se prueba que han sido
utilizadas porque son bombas de uso
restringido si se prueba que éstas han
sido utilizadas con población civil es
un es
completamente combinable y va a haber
una reacción de la comunidad
internacional la acusación es que han
sido
utilizadas contra civiles y eso es lo
que no está aprobado